bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du journal en ce mardi 3 mars
voilà ce que l'on peut retenir après
l'annulation des municipales à voisins
le bretonneux une délégation spéciale
vient d'être mise en place on verra ça
dans quelques instants
attrape des syndiqués cgt sont venus
rencontrer des salariés
et puis nous irons également à bois
d'arcy pour voir une drôle d'exposition
autour de l'egypte mais donc on démarre
ce journal avec une page politique il
n'y a plus de conseil municipal à
voisins le bretonneux pour gérer les
affaires courantes
la préfecture des yvelines a mis en
place une délégation spéciale composée
de trois personnes
le point avec michael et eni d'euros et
patrick jacques de dixmude voisins le
bretonneux n'a officiellement plus de
mer depuis le 25 février le conseil
d'état a annulé les dernières élections
municipales suite un recours déposé par
le maire sortant divers droite
alexis piette conséquence l'ensemble du
conseil municipal a démissionné en
attendant un nouveau vote
une délégation spéciale de trois
personnes va être mise en place ce
mercredi 4 mars dans la préfecture
jusqu'aux prochaines élections il faut
que ces personnes soient compétentes
faut qu'elle soit capable de gérer la
commune pendant ce temps là parce que
y'a pas que les plus de conseils du tout
il ya plus de mer alors moi en tant qu
ancien maire j'ai déjà effectivement une
certaine expérience en particulier pour
l'organisation des élections parce que
notre rôle principal
c'est d'abord de gérer pendant deux mois
mon chalet à l'espace pas grand chose
mais c'est d'organiser les élections et
que cette fois ci ça se passe bien
trois personnes ont été nommées daniel
de garn ancien maire de clairefontaine
jean marie perrin ancien officier de
l'armée de l'air et yves gibert ans au
maire de marly le roi
concrètement cette administration va
gérer les affaires courantes de la
commune
le trio pourra célébrer des mariages ou
signer les documents administratifs de
la mairie va d'abord gérer la ville au
jour le jour il ya toujours de ta
signature
à fait rien alors on le fait que dans le
cadre du budget déjà voté on n'a pas le
droit de prendre des initiatives
budgétaires
on n'a pas le droit par exemple de
lancer de nouveaux investissements cette
délégation spéciale restera jusqu'aux
prochaines élections municipales à
voisins le bretonneux prévues les
dimanches 12 et 19 avril
une page a social pour continuer la
commission exécutive confédérale de la
cgt a lancé son plan de visite des
syndicats en ile-de-france 40 au total
dans les yvelines aujourd'hui les
membres de la direction confédérale sont
allés à la rencontre de plusieurs
syndiqués sur le lieu de travail
notamment dans les locaux de cette usine
de trappes écoute pour bouleversements
dans l'organisation aux problèmes qui
ont été dits de démocratie on a décidé
d'inverser le processus
au lieu de discuter avec les syndiqués
une fois que le document d'orientation
est écrit on a décidé de l'écrire à
partir des attentes des syndiqués qu'est
ce qu'ils attendent de leur
confédération et à partir de là on
établira seulement le document
d'orientation on va leur expliquer nos
problèmes
dans un premier temps et qu'est ce que
nous a tant que petite section nous
attendons de la cgt
rencontre avec les syndiqués qui
intervient à quelques jours du 51ème
congrès départemental de la cgt qui se
tiendra du 12 au du 10 partants au 12
mars prochain ce sera aussi l'occasion
pour les adhérents et d'élire leur
nouveau président départemental et avant
de poursuivre ce journal notre question
du jour quelle image avez-vous de la cgt
nous sommes allés poser cette question
dans les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines
voici vos réponses ben je pense qu'ils
sont souvent une greffe 1.771 syndicales
dont je n'approuve pas forcément les
positions mais que je respecte parce que
c'est un syndicat comme tout syndicat
c'est indispensable à la vie sociale
tout à fond et fait partie de la société
aucun problème
le travailleur est là pour se défendre
tout simplement je pense que là ils ont
eu des épisodes un petit peu douloureux
sur sur le sujet des malversations
ce n'est pas que les dirigeants la cgt
c'est tout le monde qui est derrière ces
soucis se sont tous les syndiqués donc
je pense que pour cela il faut quand
même respecter tout ça il faut respecter
tout le mouvement et l'ensemble de tous
les syndicats cgt et l'information santé
pour continuer 116 communes et
communautés d'agglomération participait
pour la cinquième année au label commune
d'honneur de l'établissement français du
sang d'île de france
le jury a attribué un deux ou trois
coeurs en fonction de leur degré
d'implication et ainsi sur le secteur de
saint quentin en yvelines une seule
ville à primer l encours qui a reçu
trois coeurs on va parler de coeur avec
vous ou le coeur de kiba dans les
bâtiments en tout cas bonsoir elisabeth
rocha lefebvre vous êtes directrice
architectes et urbanistes également au
sein du conseil de l' architecture de
l'urbanisme de l'environnement des îles
et vous avez remis il ya quelques jours
à 30 lors et un jury a remis à trente
lauréats des prix il n'y avait pas de
prix depuis 2004 d'abord explications
pourquoi attendre dix ans pour que le
cae remettre des prix alors une de nos
manifestations sont les palmarès mais on
a beaucoup d'autres choses à faire on
est une petite équipe
donc depuis dix ans effectivement on
n'avait pas remis de prix mais c'était
encore plus intéressant de voir dix
années de construction et d'aménagement
sur le département 10 années hélas en 86
dossiers que vous avez reçu donc
c'est énorme trente lauréats quels ont
été les critères pour les critères cette
année n'ont pas été comme d'habitude
d'habitude de traditionnellement laisser
ailleurs remettre des prix plutôt par
type de bâtiment les collets enfin les
établissements scolaires les logements
etc
cette année mon équipe a proposé de
choisir trois crises cinq critères
concevoir pour durer c'est à dire
comment utilise-t-on un bâtiment avec
plusieurs vies par exemple la
réhabilitation frères ensemble comment
des acteurs peuvent travailler sur la
durée en forme pour construire mais
aussi pour inventer le futur bâtiment
dialoguer avec le contexte c'est à dire
réfléchir aux paysages à l'insertion
dans le site réalisé avec soin ça veut
tout dire
comment chaque artisan ou chaque même
l'architecte par rapport aux maîtres d
ouvrage comment on réalise les chaudes
et vivre le lieu puisque on construit
pour des habitants pour des personnes ou
pour des vies des personnes qui
n'habitent pas sur place mais qui
viennent travailler ou utiliser un
bâtiment ou un espace puisqu'il y avait
aussi des espaces publics
c'était très ouvert je dois justement
qu'on revienne sur les cinq critères sur
deux en particulier parce que ça
concerne directement de secteurs autour
de saint quentin en yvelines
par exemple le premier prix du faire
ensemble pour la reconstruction du lycée
jean-perrin de saint cyr l'école qu'est
ce qui vous a séduit dans ce projet
alors c'est fait c'est d'ailleurs en ces
mois là vous avez des images c'est un
lycée qui avait été construit
avec une certaine idée de la
construction qu'il fallait réhabiliter
le remettre aux normes l'agrandir le
transformer en site occupé donc un site
occupé c'est très compliqué et donc
l'idée de faire ensemble c'est à la fois
l'architecte avec son maître d'ouvragé
qui était la région donc travailler
ensemble sur la durée parce que la
conception c'est quelque chose de très
longs et ensuite avec les entreprises et
au milieu des élèves
donc voilà c'est cet ensemble là qui
nous a semblé être particulièrement
judicieusement fait dans ce bâtiment
pour savoir qui est très complexe parce
qu'alice et c'est très gourmands se
brosser un gros bâtiment en plus c'est
un grand bâtiment
il ya un autre pris soin que je vais
vous faire réagir ses deux prix vivre le
lieu qui est attribué à la batterie
guyancourt
alors sans doute un petit peu hein parce
qu'on voit que c'est un bâtiment qui a
imprégné dans un bâtiment déjà
historique
voilà c'était une batterie donc un d'un
des éléments d'efforts de qui ceinture
la région ile-de-france et comment
arrive-t-on à transformer un bâtiment
comme ça et lui faire vivre une nouvelle
vie
donc c'était ça l'objet et vivre le lieu
parce que comme c'est un bâtiment qui
est dédié à la musique et qui est très
investie par les musiciens
on s'est dit que ça valait le coup de
marquer cet engagement de la communauté
d'agglo de saint quentin en yvelines
pour faire revivre un bâtiment et pour
des personnes en particulier qui aiment
la musique et donc la batterie s'il
portait bien se portait bien sur ces
sujets n'ont été bien voilà c'est vrai
qu'en plus c'est très bien intégré dans
le paysage qui existait avant les prix
que vous avez remis dont il ya quelques
jours ont été remis sur le site du pôle
molière au bureau c'était c'est pas un
fait exprès parce que ce pôle molière
effectivement c'est aussi un très beau
bâtiment qui sera ouvert 7 jours sur 7
24 heures sur 24 qui fait l'objet d'une
étude très intéressante parce qu'il
permet à une école primaire une école
maternelle
nombreuses classes un gymnase unsa une
cantine qui est ouverte aussi aux
habitants un café des parents
j'en oublie beaucoup de fonctions
différentes associés dans sur un même
lieu
c'est très rare en france d'arriver à
faire ce genre de bâtiment
surtout aussi ouvert donc là il est il
vient d'être ouvert donc on en a profité
puisque la ville des mureaux avait un
prix pour l'ensemble de son projet
urbain dont le bol mois hier voudrait de
remettre nos prix cet endroit là vous
dites c'est rare de faire un bâtiment de
ces skins ça veut dire que les
architectes ne pense pas mélanger comme
ça pour les architectes très bon mind
aux commandes
donc c'est plutôt la commande arrive
voilà il faut que l'agrément de soi
réfléchi en amont par les maîtres
d'ouvragé le client et ensuite qu'on
trouve les financements et trop souvent
les financements sont très fragmenté ont
fait une école
enfin un gymnase et les financements ne
permettent pas de faire les deux en même
temps
en plus les amplitudes horaires ne sont
jamais les mêmes
les instituteurs les professeurs des
écoles aime bien avoir leur propre
bâtiment dans lequel on n'entre pas
parce que c'est plus c'est vrai que
c'est plus compliqué donc là l'objectif
c'est de faire cohabiter des usages
différents mouvements c'est un vrai
challenge
c'est un bon pari réussi dans le pot
leur dire je voudrais derniers mois
avait avec vous pour au tour donc du
conseil de l' architecture c'est aussi
accessible aux particuliers
ce n'est pas que la white possible nous
ne savons les associés voilà nous sommes
des associations créées par la loi sur
l'architecturé de 1977 dans le rôle et
la sensibilisation mais aussi le conseil
on reçoit les particuliers dans nos
locaux mais aussi dans certains points
des yvelines on conseille aussi les
collectivités et les particuliers sont
reçus gratuitement parce que
contrebalancent ils paient une taxe sur
les permis de construire pour alimenter
les cm1 qui composent donc son conseil
alors nous sommes des architectes des
urbanistes architectes urbanistes et
paysagistes
on a une documentation qui aussi ouverte
à tous les publics sur rendez vous et on
est très accueillant toutes les
personnes qui veulent recevoir un
conseil où nous poser des questions
on a un site internet sur laquelle il
trouve déjà beaucoup d'informations je
pense qu'une indiqué lundi qu'elle doit
paraître effectivement elle vous
coordonnez vous êtes un
installé à versailles pour les yvelines
merci effectivement le site internet et
le numéro de téléphone ci les
particuliers veulent s'est renseigné
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le
plateau pour nous si on va rencontrer un
autre bâtisseurs bon allez c'est pour
faire le lien
un bâtisseur d'histoire il s'appellerait
mon bilan il est passionné d'égypte il
présente en ce moment une exposition sur
ce thème et son originalité c'est qu'il
a utilisé des figurines playmobil
étonnant regardez ce reportage signé
william el est pas triché dix mille à
bois d'arcy l'été mobile revisite
l'histoire
une exposition où raymond billon
passionnés de l'egypte antique recréer
des tableaux historiques avec ses petits
jouets en plastique playmobil a réussi
un assez grand tour de force c'est que
les les personnages qu'ils ont conçu les
îlots verts vont ressembler les
personnages de l'antiquité les soldes
avec dortoirs mais comme dans
l'antiquité
c'est la conception réaliste de ses
personnages qui a attiré cet amateur lui
permettant de remettre en scène des
passages de l'histoire il ya un tableau
avec des saynètes par exemple et
j'allais dire entre guillemets les les
obsèques de phares en comparaison des
professions les processions nous ferons
avec son épouse la reine construction
d'un gouverneur en fait là un peu la vie
paysanne
ici pas loin de 5000 pièces sont réunis
et pour s'éloigner un peu du nil me
petite partie de l'exposition est
réservé à l'ère romaine histoire de
découvrir deux grandes civilisations de
l'époque en plastique
ce journal est maintenant terminé merci
de l'avoir suivi vous avez rendez vous
dans quelques instants avec le wef richy
pour le 7-8 politique il recevra
empattement plateau stéphane mans son
professeur de droit qui donnera son
éclairage à la fois sur la municipale
partielle à voisins le bretonneux et à
la fois sur le nouveau mode de scrutin
des élections départementales et puis
également ce soir entre 19h et 20h ne
manquez pas le premier débat des
départementales du canton de trappes je
souhaite une excellente soirée